well louise hague is shadow transport
secretary she joins us now thanks very
much sir louise hague for being with us
let's start we're getting these
extraordinary um uh stories from on
board some of these piano ferries of uh
people agency workers in balaclavas
coming on to try and escort uh now
redundant p o staff off boats is is that
something first of all that you're
hearing because again we're hearing that
piano staff are not supposed to talk uh
to the press and what's your reaction to
that yes i've heard and been speaking to
directly with um crew members and
seafarers who uh overnight or this
morning have been told that they will be
losing their jobs and are now attempting
to stay on the ships in order to try and
fight for those jobs and protect
themselves security firms and agency
workers have been busting who are
handcuff trained and are trying to
remove those workers from the ships and
it's just
unforgivable it is frankly a complete
and utter scandal that a company should
be behaving like this on british soil to
tell hundreds of workers on zoom on a
pre-recorded zoom that they're going to
be losing their jobs and then to try and
physically remove them from their ships
when they've done absolutely nothing
wrong there is absolutely no financial
situation that piano could be in that
could merit this kind of behavior now
we're hoping to speak to
the head of nautilus one of the the
unions uh later in the program but are
you having conversations with uh unions
at the moment and what are they advising
because we're hearing some people have
been told don't get off those ships
because you might find yourself locked
out of your job should they be staying
on board if they are there already
well yes the unions are advising that
the workers stay on the ships but
clearly there are really serious health
and safety concerns to this if um agency
security workers are walking on wearing
balaclavas and handcuff trained then i'm
fearful for the safety of those workers
on those ships but they're doing
everything they can
to protect and fight for their jobs
frankly this is nothing less than an
assault on british seafaring and all of
us in opposition alongside our friends
in the trade union movement and the
government need to be doing everything
we can to say this is completely
unacceptable no ifs no but we cannot
allow a company like pno to treat their
workers like this and if it is legal it
it stretches you know credulity that it
could be legal and i know the uh rmt are
seeking an injunction as we speak but um
if it is legal then we need to
immediately make sure that we enact
legislation to stop this ever happening
again but piano
received an enormous amount of taxpayers
money during furlough
and i'd want to see the government
clawing every penny of that back if they
continue down this path an injunction in
part presumably because there was no
consultation on on this before what
would a labour government have sought to
do with this because this was clearly
kept secret from the government uh until
now no one seems to have known about
this uh what would a labour government
have done differently
well yeah i mean that we've all been
caught on the hop it's been a surprise
to everyone this morning but we've been
calling on the government for
years now to end fire and rehire because
this could well be what piano are trying
to do get rid of its workforce and then
hire them back on lesser um terms and
conditions and lesser pay that's almost
certainly what they will attempt to do
in the coming weeks and months we've
also been calling over many years for
domestic law to properly apply to
international shipping routes because
this may well be one of the ways they're
trying to get around this we've seen
over a decade now of an assault on
workers rights from successive tory
governments and this is an unscrupulous
company making use of the lacks
employment rights that we now have in
this country but the government has in
its power now to convene the workforce
can convene the unions and the employer
and to look at every single leader that
they have in government to
make sure that p can't be allowed to get
away with this when you say can't be
allowed to get away with this the
problem is they've already fired them
they say they're going to give them a
very generous compensation package but
the idea of them rehiring those same
workers seems to be for the birds
doesn't it what what can the government
do now
well um you know
british airways went through a similar
process to this just a couple of years
ago when they attempted to fire and
rehire their staff and actually it was a
concerted campaign led by the unions but
joined by politicians from across
parties that made british airways um
re re-hire their staff on similar terms
and conditions and stop that assault on
workers so
i would i would urge everyone to make
clear their disgust at this and it's
it's reminiscent actually to something
pno did back in the 80s when there was
a massive campaign around that don't go
pno clearly that needs resurrecting if
they're going to go ahead with this um
but government does have levers when
it's power it's given public money to
that company that should be clawed back
and it should be reviewing every single
potential contract that it has with pno
or its parent company dpw which
currently runs ports across the uk
800 people represents a fifth of piano's
workforce i mean it's a it's a huge
number 800 people now suddenly finding
themselves without jobs at a time like
this what does that mean uh for those
people facing you know what we're all
going to go through the cost of living
crisis
exactly i mean it's just absolutely
devastating we're in the middle of a
catastrophe
of living standards petrol rising at the
pumps energy bills about to soar and
real wages are falling for the first
time in a long time this will
mean breaking point for many families
and particularly in the areas most
affected like whole
roundover um
you know it it's it's just absolutely
heartbreaking and i know those workers
will be doing everything they can to
save their jobs but it is really
reminiscent of what has been you know
done before to these kind of workers
back in the 80s under previous tory
governments and it will lead many
families and many communities to
breaking point yeah no it's a grim
thought louise hague shadow transport
secretary thanks very much for joining
us here on sky